[Applaudissements]
qui a quelque chose à nous annoncer
bonsoir j'ai une bonne nouvelle très
très bonne nouvelle chez vous avez su un
petit peu d'actu médias ces derniers
jours
moi ouais j'ai une gueule est ce que
j'ai une gueule à ne pas suivre l'actu
média roulement dont on a une bonne
nouvelle mais peut-être vu passer on en
a parlé un petit peu aussi de la gauche
à droite
sachez que tpm peur on s'était lancé un
défi était pmp a réussi à atteindre un
chiffre qu'on pense encore inimaginables
yates à quatre jours sachez le
on a atteint les 2 millions de
téléspectateurs
c'est grâce à vous les chéris vraiment
hewitt et pmp fait bon basket
on vous explique en fait c'est que
exactement donc voilà donc en fait on
effet un mignon un million neuf cent
mille téléspectateurs sur le prime et il
ya tellement de gens qui sont allés voir
le replay casque il ya une semaine après
vous avez de vrais audiences médiamétrie
c'est cette audience la qui comptera
d'ailleurs ces deux millions 47 mille
téléspectateurs qui ont suivi
tpm p faites vos voeux donc on s'est dit
c'est peut-être le moment le moment d'y
aller à las vegas non on va partir
je vous le dire on va vraiment partir à
las vegas et la grappa de mythos de las
vegas voilà en isère ou deux trucs à las
vegas un un restaurant qui s'appelle las
vegas j'ai déjà pris les devants et ont
tiré les - ouais avec 5 à 1 va vraiment
partir à las vegas pour le moment il n'y
a que camille combal et moi qui partent
1 c'est un mariage est un mariage pour
l'instant camier mois nous partout et je
vous le dis on amènera dit
téléspectateurs avec nous quatre jours à
las vegas est sûr et certain et chérie
on lancera sa demande
demain on commencera vous sélectionné
pour partir à las vegas camille va vous
donner une petite enveloppe à chacun les
férus ti et à partir et à partir de
demain dès le début de l'émission
chaque jour il y aura un chroniqueur qui
gagnera n'avait attendait il y aura
chroniqueurs qui gagnera sa sélection
pour las vegas c'est à dire que nous on
pas pour l'un pour l'instant sort pas
nous je vous le dis il n'y aura que
camille mois et six chroniqueurs qui je
montrais dans la soute vers une laisse
rien percer un solide et alors là je
rencontre peut penser vous changez vous
passerez pas la douane sans rigoler
c'est j'ai pas de la vanne donc à partir
de demain il y aura les sélections pour
las vegas
vous ferez il y aura un jeu tous les
jours alors à qualifier tous les jours
pour partir à las vegas il faudra tout
donner
nous ça y est on a les billets effet et
vous avez vous alors valérie vdn qu'est
ce que vous avez reçus et bien à 2
millions et jean chapet l'on se marie
camille et baba vous convier à leur
mariage mais il faudra mériter votre
place pour vegas est exactement
exactement à la mériter la place match
josé pas le faire par c'est normal